en la elección pasada nos enfocamos en
la geometría de la piel de dinosaurio y
en las escamas y usamos los diagramas de
voronoi para obtener la estructura que
estábamos buscando pero simplificamos el
acabado de la piel utilizando solo dos
colores sólidos sin textura es por eso
que nuestro resultado final no se veía
tan real no pusimos los detalles finales
que vemos en la piel de adeveras cuando
observas tu propia piel ves un solo
color no yo veo una variación en color y
textura esa variación se vuelve más
clara cuando vemos las cosas bajo
algunos aumentos o con más resolución
esta es una imagen de la piel humana con
una resolución muy alta guau nos revela
todo un mundo de variación de textura y
color no se ve ni suave y de color
sólido cierto y como vemos diferentes
patrones con resoluciones distintas
decimos que las superficies naturales
tienen una estructura multi resolución
veamos otro ejemplo de esto en nuestro
paquete de acabados tenemos una imagen
de un cocodrilo como referencia para las
escamas de dinosaurio
es lo que vemos con resolución muy baja
la piel está llena de bultos y el color
es interesante observa el patrón de
tablero de ajedrez en las escamas y en
cada escama el color se ve bastante
sólido aumentemos la resolución y aquí
podemos ver unas escamas más pequeñas
que se ven bastante suaves y redondas y
hay más variedad de color que antes no
veíamos parecía un salpicado de color
provocado por la pigmentación natural y
por la tierra otra referencia para la
piel de dinosaurio es la piel de víbora
con esta resolución baja parece una
colección de escamas blancas y negras
pero con una resolución más alta vemos
más detalles del color las escamas
blancas contienen pequeños puntos cafés
y las escamas negras tienen una
coloración clara en los bordes y si
seguimos aumentando la resolución las
cosas se ponen bastante locas
a eso da miedo parece que entre más
cerca observas más encuentras exacto y
esta es la esencia de las estructuras
con multi resolución el color y la
textura de un objeto son el resultado de
todos los detalles juntos antes de
aplicar estas ideas a la piel de
dinosaurio detengámonos para hacer que
te sientas cómodo viendo el mundo con
diferentes resoluciones en el próximo
ejercicio
el reto es identificar superficies en
distintas resoluciones pero recuerda las
cosas no siempre son lo que parecen cuál
es tu ejemplo favorito en el que hayas
trabajado que tenga una mezcla
interesante de patrones en el viaje de
arlo los pterodáctilos cada parte de su
cuerpo tenía un montón de texturas la
cresta tenía una textura similar a la
del cerebro daba un poco de asco y en el
cuello usamos una textura como de lava
seca para darle un aspecto de arrugas
para las alas nos basamos en la piel de
elefante para que fuera un poco más
suave y el cuerpo tenía una piel muy
seca con una sensación como la de iu
casa llamas estaba muy bonito todo
encajó perfecto y usamos técnicas de
iluminación para hacerlo más interesante
y mezclamos varias texturas para pasar
de una parte del cuerpo a la siguiente
que estás viendo muy bien